good morning um welcome to the final
subcommittee meeting on the retained
bail bills if you would join me please
Allegiance i al Flag stes America the
for it stands one nation God
all that is both a sign of my patriotism
and a test to make sure that I'm not
getting early onset
Alzheimers um because I've been
forgetting a lot we are going to break
for a short period perod of time some of
these bills we've just seen for the
first time um one of them I just got
back from alls on my way in this morning
in my car so needless to say I did not
have time to go over in depth so we are
going to break until 10:30 um when we
will
reconvene to see if we are ready to take
these up so until then we're on a
break um Republican members if you would
please
e
252 okay all right um line
four
RSA
63a okay is it okay we had agreed that
the 632 A3 would be removed as well as
this line five where it was
333a okay 653a I'm sorry let me back up
sexual assault domestic violence under
oh is that the misdemeanor domestic
violence yes okay and should not be
there and then the other one was um the
for
right
I'm me a second s
um we agreed that we were going to keep
632 the aggravated yes but I just but
the next one over 632
A3 that's the one I'm fonex right that
was the other one huh
no yes why
it
I believe the two that we discussed uh
the two charges we discussed were
domestic violence under RSA
631 uh colon
2B uh and stocking under RSA 63 3 colon
uh 3A um the those are misdemeanor uh
misdemeanor offenses um they can be
felonies so so for example if a deadly
weapon uh is used or was threatened to
be used um then a person would be
charged under the domestic violence
statute with a felony rather than a
misdemeanor um and uh stalking uh if a
person has a prior conviction
the person would be charged with a
felony uh rather than a misdemeanor uh
part of the issue is all of the
testimony that we heard from the court
system about how those two particular
charges in uh uh in general would just
create uh a lot of additional hearings
uh that would basically Drive the cost
of this uh way way up and and given the
fact that we have uh uh additional
protection for domestic violence uh
victims uh elsewhere in the package
we'll be talking about uh today um we
may want to modify uh that language yeah
we had an agreement on that and I am
sticking to it um I had told all us only
the Felon ver felony versions so what
what we need here is we need to
specify um for stalking we need to say
um I don't know if it would it suffice
to say felonius stalking or would it or
should we say stalking second fon should
cover it right and the same thing with
domestic violence it should say fonus
domestic violence and that should take
one hold on I'm trying to find where
about oh you're talking about yeah we're
not talking about that one that's that's
staying that is a felony we're talking
about the next one domestic violence we
need to we need to specify felonius and
then we're talking about um line
um 632 A3 which is wait a minute no
that's delonia sexual
salt where's the stocking one
David oh here it is yeah line five um it
says stalking under RSA 633 colon 3
we're going to add the word felonius
under that that's all just to ensure
that those two crimes are only the
felony versions that will be um
referenced as being held for a
judge okay so I've made the note of
those two things we will submit that
that change um let's move on next bill
we're not
okay
two
personing probable cause of this yeah
okay um instead of probable cause clear
and convincing yeah we we we've gone
over that one and um if someone is held
someone for someone to be arrested on a
charge of one of these violent heinous
charges the threshold is probable cause
to arrest them and generally you would
have what's called a probable cause
hearing um to set the bar for these
crimes and we don't do it anywhere else
in the statutes except for these crimes
higher than the threshold to make the
arrest in other words a police officer
arrested someone for for
example kidnapping and they they've got
probable cause to believe they committed
the kidnapping by making it clear and
convincing we've set the standard higher
for the so there's a threshold enough to
arrest them and prove that they did it
but now we're going to set even higher
standard to say they can be held um and
that that doesn't seem to make any sense
now I didn't try to apply that to any of
the other statutes that we've addressed
only this one that the Senate and we
agreed on for the felonious charges um
so I'm open to discuss that if if if you
think that um if you think that that's
why well when we talked about it in the
past um I don't know that we really
addressed this during the hearings much
we heard from two County uh County
attorneys who said that setting that
burden of clear and convincing was um
very difficult for them to meet um at
that early stage because they haven't
even gotten a trial yet um having said
that I did not change it for the rest of
the bail statutes just for these crimes
here that's the only place you'll see a
change to probable
cause um so uh I'm like I said anyone
have any substantial
David represent me sorry I'm that's okay
um one of the things is that the the
eviden evidentiary standard um does
increase you know with each additional
encounter a defendant has with the court
system so so for instance the standard
of evidence required you know for uh for
holding a person on bail is different
from the standard of evidence required
to convict that person um
so one of the things that uh that just
strikes me strikes me about this is
after you've had time to uh to organize
thoughts uh begin to put put a case
together um
the probable cause as an evidentiary
standard is about as low on the rung as
we can possibly get um and uh you know
the whole idea that we're seeing a judge
um you know to me you know it it entails
that there would be some sort of higher
evidentiary standard to hold hold a
person you can hold a person based on
probable cause but but um you know to
actually continue to hold them to me
require should require some higher
evidentiary
standard thank you representative Stone
thank you Mr chair I would uh support
the probable cause standard when the
individual goes before a a Justice they
understand probable cause and I think if
you add a higher degree just for the
purpose of detention you kind of uh I
don't know it just looks like you're
really setting three standards of uh
probable cause you have articulable
suspicion you have clear and
convincing Beyond a reasonable doubt I
would say that a judge is more than
capable of finding probable cause for a
detention
hearing um the the only issue I have is
that in and this is the way I see it
this this occurs relatively shortly
after the arrest um I mean we're talking
what are the they have to be heard
um within 24 hours um and if we're
setting a higher standard within 24
hours that what it really does is it
raises the threshold to
arrest for to clear and convincing
evidence because if the if the officer
has probable cause at the point of
arrest within 24 hours he has to have a
higher standard now to have the person
who is arrested for one of these crimes
we're talking about murder a sexual
assault felonius um it's that's a very
short time period for them to develop
their case enough to make the the next
higher burden of clear and convincing
and we're only talking about these very
violent um horrible crimes not the
entire bail system so that that's just
my my thoughts on that is that you you
may as well change the standard to
arrest for these crimes to clear and
convincing because you've only got 24
hours to come up with more evidence to
meet the next burden and frankly I'm not
even sure if someone can articulate what
that what the difference is between
probable cause and clear and convincing
um within that 24-hour period
representative Stone do you have
a idea of the difference of those two
standards to me it's a practical matter
as we're going back to having
individuals arraigned on probable cause
hearings for felonies at the circuit
court level at that time typically in
the past before they had felonies first
the uh probable cause hearing was
usually determined if there was probable
cause for the arrest of the charges and
at the same time time normally the
issues of bail were raised at that time
to see if the defendant should be
released or if they should remain in
custody and like you said Mr chair I
think if you have somebody getting
arrested and going before a judge within
you know 24 hours what facts and
circumstances are really changing from
the point of arrest to the point where
you're going up for a bill hearing it's
a you're really not gaining anything
you're still having an initial
appearance you're really not having a uh
wellth thought out strategy to argue
bail unless you know there's an attorney
involved at a later stage that can
articulate why an individual shouldn't
be held or why the prosecutor feels they
should be held I just don't see that
there's such a narrow scope of time that
you can't really validate a different
standard other than probable
cause and there is um they are entitled
to a further hearing after this if I'm
not mistaken
correct that would be
correct so this is the initial
appearance on one of these serious
crimes
that we talking about not not the final
decision on whether or not they get
bailed any other thoughts representative
Murray um yeah I think you're right
there like we were we would in this case
it would be a hearing still until they
had an official bail hearing before the
court right so it's still not um the
other thing I was wondering though is
this like probable cause that like
they've committed the crime or is it
probable cause that a danger to you know
what I mean that's that's a good point
that's a good point um first what you
said originally um regarding this is
their first appearance and we did not
change the language for the next for the
bail hearing which is clear and
convincing so their bail hearing is
still clear and convincing evidence this
is the original appearance where it's
probable cause and it is probable cause
that they're a danger not that
necessarily that they committed the
crime crime however with these crimes I
I would argue that the um the very
nature of the crime itself if there's
probable cause to believe you did it
there's probable cause to believe you're
dangerous um which is why I would assume
the Senate picked these dangerous crimes
other words if there's probable cause to
believe that you committed robbery it's
probable that you're also dangerous um
if there's probable cause to believe
that you committed felonia sexual
assault which is rape it's probably that
you're dangerous so I think that that's
the reason the Senate picked those and
that's the reason that for this initial
appearance not the bail hearing that
they're entitled to after but the
initial appearance before a magistrate
or the judge the um the standard is
basically the same as the arrest that
was made just 24 hours earlier further
discussion anyone else have any thoughts
that one thing I I I do want to say is
the fact that um
uh in the amendment uh we are specifying
uh that the hearing needs to take place
within 24 hours actually helps a lot of
things um and this this I this is one of
them okay all right so can we can we
agree to leave that then probable causes
anyone I think that we is for this
initial
hearing considering they are entitled to
a further bail hearing representative
wheeler you look like you want to say
something do you I mean
if there is I don't want to blow up the
agreement I just think that there might
be some constitutional questions with
whether or not someone can be held
because this is about someone's uh
Flight Risk or dangerousness and I think
that there may be some constitutional
I'm not a constitutional scholar but I
think that there may be some
constitutional question as to whether or
not um that is kosher with our
constitution in terms of clear and
convincing rather than than probable for
someone being held and determining
dangerousness based on probable cause or
or clear and convincing evidence so that
would be my only uh trepidation I guess
but if the committee agrees then well um
I'm also not a constitutional scholar
however I did sleep on a good bed last
night and I have researched this a
little bit many states the standard um
what you have is a probable cause
hearing to determine whether or not you
should be help because if there's not
probable cause you're released so um I I
think it's clearly constitutional it's
just a matter of what we decide and I
think that as a state we have left the
clear and convincing standard alone for
the bail hearing itself not this initial
appearance um we say that we want a
little bit more evidence to hold
somebody but in the case of just these
crimes which are pretty heinous and just
for their initial appearance um we
shouldn't require law enforcement to
develop a higher standard within 24
hours than they needed to arrest the
person that that's my that's my thing
and if to representative M's point if if
this weren't within 24 hours if it was
say 72 hours or more then I would agree
okay they have some time to develop this
a little bit more but seeing as this is
the initial appearance that we set at 24
hours because we want to give people a
chance to get out we also have to think
of the state and the victim and say okay
we we don't want to make a higher burden
um within 24 hours
so
um all right let's move on to the next
um issue I think actually one additional
issue we wanted to on 252 yeah that's
what I wanted to add oh okay yeah what
else do you
got well there's the um the issue of uh
electronic monitoring um the the at the
the very end um can you give me a line
number and a p oh sorry well this is uh
line uh page two line it starts at uh 28
and ends at 32 if I'm not not mistaken
um and we're we would like there to be a
uh warrant issued for any other tracking
info other than where that person is
relative to their ba bail conditions
okay that that doesn't sound
unreasonable I just have to find where
you are um well we're looking to add it
at the end of line 32 on page two line
32 where it says the court May seek
reimbursement you want to add another
sentence after that which or a sentence
within that paragraph that related to
electronic monitoring wherever OS thinks
it makes sense that says that uh a
warrant must be issued for any extra
information other than related to what
that person's bail conditions are okay
all right let's think that through for a
second the court is the one who is
ordering the electronic monitoring they
the same person who would issue a
warrant the electronic monitoring is
being conducted by the court or whoever
they hire to do it and the instructions
are that in the I don't know what line
it is that says that they report
violations directly to the police
department but that's all so I could see
a warrant for the police to obtain any
other information that is recorded by
this is that would that be sufficient I
think that would be sufficient so that
they can't say hey what else you got
exactly the concern is uh police being
able to access the electronic monitoring
information for extra things which AG
would you know create some
constitutional consc do the members
agree the rest of the yeah conversation
that we did we did have I remember that
yeah represent
M yeah the reason the reason for this is
a court case called Commonwealth versus
Norman Massachusetts Virginia or
Pennsylvania um and one of the things I
would say is that um are are judges in
New Hampshire may be even more
protective of privacy than judges in
Massachusetts I agree um so um one of
the things that I I wanted to suggest if
we're looking for a place to put this
yeah down at the bottom of page three uh
under line 37 uh what we could do is add
yeah one more section uh section d d d
yeah and where it something like this Mr
chair a law enforcement officer shall
not use monitoring data for any other
purpose other than ensuring the accused
does not violate conditions of bail or a
protective order a warrant shall be
obtained for any other usage that sounds
perfect
okay
this
well I was just gonna I think we were
had the same thought uh the only other
thing that we had to add was
um on the six uh 53 the in Branch uh
commission yeah we would we would like
to add something which says that the
legislative branch should be the chair
of the commission uh because we've heard
testimony which says that the court
being uh chair of this commiss has
created some friction you know we
actually just discussed that ourselves
um the only concern I have with that and
I I'm I'm happy either way is the
legislature often has some turnover and
that would prevent continuity in
leadership if for example I got made
chair and then I don't get reelected or
choose not to run next time you have a
new chair coming in and I mean you would
have continuity for two years at a time
at least so I either way if if you guys
really feel like that's important um
then we can put that the um the
legislative um member be the chair
that's fine with me it was representa
Katherine the other piece is um I think
that we had the conversation like um um
two folks from the legislative branch to
from the Senate and we talked about
those types of things because I don't
see any of that well that here we need
the actual um original commission does
anyone can we let's see if we can get
the original um the original bill that
created this commission is what we need
because it's all listed in there who's
on it and what their rules are so we
would have to actually address that okay
if you guys don't have any other changes
to discuss we'll take a break and get
that and then reconvene in 15 minutes
how's that yeah everyone agreement
represent me did you have something
before we do that okay all right 15
um
e
and we're
back um at this point a couple things
first we're going to um quickly discuss
the change regarding the makeup of
the of the um inter Branch criminal ju
Justice and criminal and Juvenile
Justice
Council
um based on recommendations we received
from people that were involved before um
we're going to amend add to the bill um
which bill was it that talked about that
653 653 to just make one change that um
currently it says the
members elect a chair from among
themselves we're going to put it that
the um the legislative member from the
criminal justice committee will chair
the commission or committee or councel
um that way um for a couple reasons
since the purpose of this is to
recommend legislation it should be a
legislator who knows the makeup of the
house and how things are going in the
house that shares it um we we recognize
that the person could change every
couple years um but that would be the
case anyway because a new speaker can
change at any point who he puts on
commissions or councils or committees so
we feel like that that's negligible So
based on the recommendations we received
we're going to make that change let's
use
653 now I'm going to attempt to go
through all the changes that we're going
to make TOs and what we're going to do
is we're just going to agree on it and
then we're going to go over to OS and
we'll get the final version printed for
tomorrow that way we don't have to stay
here all day waiting for the the changes
so let me go go through the builds I
them may notice that I'm somewhat
chair the changes that we just agreed to
well we changed 249 I believe a couple
things right 2
252 Oh actually 249 um there's a
reference in 249 on page five line 22 to
apparently to a statute that doesn't
exist um it says subject to RSA 597 col
2 10 and 11
um they're unable to find an 11 anywhere
so I'm going to have to seek clar
verification on what that's supposed to
be or strike it that's the first
one then
we agreed to
change we're going to require we're
going to add a section D um on page
three at the bottom that says law
enforcement um cannot use the
information obtained through the
electronic monitoring for any other
purpose and if they wish to get any
warrant
and looks like that was it was there
anything else that I'm missing that we
change
notating yes oh yes and um that's also
what bill is that that's that's 22 252
as well hold
on and also on 252 where the list of
crimes are are we agreed that we are
going to specify felonious domestic
violence
and bonus
stalking and I believe that was
it does that sound right so that
wouldn't be in those two rsas right
which one what do you mean okay so RSA 6
yeah they would have to change whatever
RSA to make sure it fits the felonius so
the whole thing would have to be changed
language well because we still want the
felony
verion you know what I mean yeah okay
otherwise the Senate's not going to conc
okay any other any other questions
everyone agree with those changes if
everyone's agreement um please anyone
how about this anyone who disagrees
who's on the subcommittee with any of
the changes I just listed based on that
are we all in agreement um to send this
to LS and this is what we will present
to the full committee
tomorrow um let me just take a
representative tenar yes representative
Stone yes representative Muse yes
representative Murray representative
Reed yes representative Pratt yes
representative Willer yep representative
here at gath R that's a one question oh
dear God I know all right going back to
the probable cause and the clear and the
convincing yeah um I really would like
to be certain that that's not um that
it's okay to use that and it's not you
know affecting um as you said our
constitutional rights um okay the only
way to to be certain of that would be to
ask the court and I don't think we have
time to get the opinion of the court on
that um as I spoke to a representative
from the ACLU who voiced a similar
concern if it turns out that that would
be
unconstitutional they can bring that um
to the Senate and I told them I would
not um not concur because of that if it
comes that it has to go back to that it
just has to go back to that um that's
really not really not our purview if
it's already been decided
constitutionally so is that good yes
okay so and the chair votes yes so based
on that I'm going to go to OS get those
changes and I will see you all tomorrow
morning for our final vote um on all of
the um retained bills that we have um uh
Republican members will be caucusing at
9:00 a.m. tomorrow morning um did you
want to make an announcement for your um
your group are you going to
caucus yep n nine and representative
okay well then you should retain that
for tomorrow at the full
committee um does that make more oh sure
today